(mouse clicking)
- It's my distinct pleasure to introduce
our first speaker of the morning.
And we have to pay rapt attention
and if she allows time for questions
at the conclusion of her talk,
we have to be very concise
because she is headed off at 9, what time?
9:15 for her uber to the airport
to be en route to Taiwan
for an invited lectureship.
And we are honored to have
this morning Dr. Yvonne Wu,
who first spoke at the
conference 16 years ago
and her, I think she was
pregnant with her daughter Clara,
who is 16 now and is
here at this conference.
It really is a pleasure to
see Yvonne and Clara today.
Yvonne is Professor of Neurology
and Pediatrics at UCSF,
an expert on newborn brain injury
and risk factors for cerebral palsy,
which constitutes much
of today's presentations
before we segue into all autism.
And Yvonne is currently
running a large trial,
testing a new therapy that could
help prevent cerebral palsy.
Welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much,
it's really a pleasure
and an honor to be here, especially
with all the other distinguished speakers.
I'm unfortunately running
off, as you heard,
so I won't be able to stay for
the question answer session
but I would be happy
to take a few questions
at the end if there's time.
So I'll be talking today about
some of the work we're doing
and also a lot of other people are doing
to find ways to prevent CP,
specifically in newborns
with hypoxic-ischemic encephalopathy.
And I have nothing to disclose.
So we're gonna start by just reviewing
what we know generally about causes of CP
and why I wanna focus today
on hypoxic-ischemic encephalopathy,
which is another term for birth asphyxia.
Then we're gonna talk about
the standard of care right now
for treating babies with this condition
and that is to cool them, that's
actually a cooling blanket
that you see that baby is sleeping on.
And then we'll talk about the work
that we and others have done to look at
whether adding another
therapy, erythropoietin,
might provide it
additional neuroprotection.
And then finally in the final few minutes,
I'll rush through few other
experimental treatments
that are being studied.
So all of you in this room have treated
and taken care of patients
with cerebral palsy
and you know that the list of
potential causes is very long.
But I think it's helpful to
think in broad categories
and it's pretty well established
that half of all children
with cerebral palsy
are born preterm and they
are susceptible specifically
to brain injury of prematurity.
And so we're not gonna talk
about this group today,
we're gonna talk instead
about term infants.
And they make up half of the kids with CP
and you'll see in the
green slice of the pie
that about 15% of those will be found
to have abnormal formation of the brain.
So a brain dysgenesis.
And then there's a small sliver of the pie
that constitutes postnatal injury
in the first month of life.
But the majority of infants
who are born at term
who have cerebral palsy
are thought to have
a relatively normally
developing brain in utero,
but then something happens in
the prenatal, perinatal
period to injure the brain.
And what do those injuries look like?
Well so, if you see, really
the only way to know clinically
is to do a brain MRI to see
what kind of brain injury occurred.
And so, you know, if a child has severe
quadriplegic cerebral palsy,
one of the more common
findings is this one up here.
If you look here, the
basal ganglia and thalami
are these deep gray
structures of the brain.
All that white signal indicates injury
to those deep gray structures,
and that will typically give you
severe spastic quadriplegia.
Alternatively you might do an
MRI and see abnormal signal
in what we call the
parasaggital areas of the brain,
just parallel to the midline.
That involves more of the white
matter and overlying cortex,
so that's called watershed injury.
And these kids might have less
severe motor abnormalities
but have more cognitive
issues and seizures.
If a child has a hemiplegic cerebral palsy
and you do an MRI, often what
you'll see is this stroke,
an area that, in this case,
is an arterial stroke,
where there's a clot that
formed in one of the arteries.
You can also get a clot
in the venous structures
here in the superior sagittal sinus
and that can cause injury to the brain.
You might see a child that
had a hemorrhage early on.
And so these are all potential causes
of the motor disability that we see.
So we're gonna focus today on HIE,
hypoxic-ischemic encephalopathy.
And that specifically gives
you these typical pictures,
the basal ganglia injury
and the watershed injury.
And why are we focusing
on this particular issue?
I think that, first of all,
although it doesn't
account for the majority
of that pie of the
causes of cerebral palsy,
it is an important condition
that accounts for a
significant proportion.
But most importantly it's
well studied in animal models,
it's well studied in cell culture,
and so we have a basic understanding
on a molecular and cellular
level of what happens
when the brain has an insult,
where there's decreased
oxygen and blood flow.
And because of that understanding
and because of the animal
models that are out there,
you can devise and test
neuroprotective strategies
to try to help the brain recover better.
And so I sort of think of
it as low hanging fruit
in that way because of all the great work
that's been done by basic researchers
and is certainly ripe for clinical trials.
So okay, so what is HIE?
So as the term implies,
hypoxic-ischemic encephalopathy,
it implies that there's reduced oxygen
and blood flow to the brain.
This is just a schematic showing that,
you know, the blood that
should be red is blue,
suggesting there's hypoxia.
And because of the decreased blood flow,
you often get the deep gray nuclei
that are specifically
susceptible to this insult.
That is where you see the injury,
as we saw in the MIR scans.
And then you can also get injury
specifically in the white matter,
just lateral to the midline.
So this is the condition
that we're talking about.
So HIE, as I said, is a
very important condition.
You know, it's not just an
important condition here
but especially around the world.
It occurs in one to three
per 1,000 live births
but in low and middle income countries
can be as high as 26 per 1,000.
In the US there are about 12,000 infants
who suffer from this every year.
And worldwide, it accounts for almost 1/4
of all neonatal deaths.
And if it's untreated, this
is from the day and age
when I trained, in the 1990s,
I mean basically, you know,
there wasn't much treatment available
and untreated, about 1/3 of
severely affected infants
will die in the newborn period.
Another 1/3 will develop
longterm motor disabilities.
And you know, this is
another whole talk in itself
but what is causing the HIE?
You know, occasionally five to 15%,
depending on the study you look at,
you can put your finger on what caused it.
You can say oh, there was abruption,
so major maternal blood loss
or there was a uterine rupture.
And in those cases you
know something happened
to decrease the oxygenation
and blood flow to the baby's brain.
But the majority of the time,
we really don't understand what caused it,
which means we also really don't know
how to prevent it very well.
And that's again, a whole
other talk in itself.
But as I mentioned, you know,
things have changed since
I first trained in the 90s,
because we, I shouldn't say we,
the basic scientists realized
that after this initial period of insult,
the decreased oxygen and
blood flow to the brain,
there's, you know,
definitely an initial period
of primary cell death, where
some of the neurons will die.
But then there's this evolution of injury
that occurs over hours and days
and a lot of these
intracellular mechanisms
that lead to secondary energy failure,
leads to a secondary delayed
phase of neuronal death are,
you know, pretty well
studied in animal studies.
So there's apoptosis, this
like programmed cell death.
You know, there's a lot
of glutamate toxicity,
excitotoxic injury, there's inflammation,
all of these things take time
and that gives us a window to intervene.
And so the first, the
next part of this talk
is really to focus a
little bit on hypothermia.
And so, you know, the nice
thing is that hypothermia
is started within a few hours after birth
and is kept on for several days
and counteracts all these things that
are happening to cause
further brain injury.
And this is just a schematic
that shows that hypothermia
is a potent neuroprotective
therapy in these babies.
It protects the brain and the reason is
that it has all these properties,
it has anti-excitotoxic properties.
So here's a glutamate NMDA receptor
and you actually have
decreased excitotixicity.
There's decreased reactive oxygen species
and antioxidant effects, there's
anti-inflammatory effects.
This is the cell nucleus
and there's decreased
apoptotic cell deaths.
So it has multiple
effects on this process.
And so you would think that
it would be very very potent.
And in fact it has been shown now,
definitively in multiple clinical trials,
that this treatment reduces death
or moderate to severe disability.
And therefore has become standard of care.
And so, there are two ways of
doing this cooling therapy,
you can either cool
the whole body at birth
or you can put on a cool
cap and just cool the head,
both have been found to work,
as far as we know, equally well.
Most places do body
cooling, it's easier to do,
you use a cooling blanket and
you can still do a full EEG
because you don't have a cap on your head.
It has to be begun by six hours of age.
That's, you know, typically
the way it's used.
And we cool the core body temperature
down to 33.5 degrees for 72 hours
and then rewarm them
gradually over six hours.
So this is now standard of care.
What does this have to
do with cerebral palsy?
So as I mentioned, it's
been shown to reduce death
and moderate to severe disability.
This group did a meta analysis looking at,
I think six or seven large
multicenter clinical trials,
testing the use of hypothermia
and you can see there's reduced
death, reduced disability.
And if you look specifically
at cerebral palsy,
there's a relative risk of 0.62.
So the risk of cerebral palsy
in these babies with HIE,
if they get cooled, is 38%
lower, if they get cooled.
And you can take these
numbers and calculate
what we call a number needed to treat
and it comes out to eight.
So for every eight babies
with HIE who get cooled,
you can actually prevent one case of CP.
So this was a game changer for us.
I mean I trained and we spent, you know,
I guess from the 90s until 2007,
when we saw babies with
HIE, we would support them,
treat them if they had seizures
but there was no other specific therapy.
Starting in 2007, we
started cooling at UCSF
and the standard of care
in most larger facilities.
And so, yeah, these are
just additional data
from the three largest cooling studies.
The NICHD study in the US multicenter,
TOBY was a European study,
and then there's a large CoolCap study.
And if you put the results
from those together,
if you get cooled, these babies have a,
you know, significantly lower rate
of death or moderate severe disability.
And their risk of CP,
as I mentioned earlier,
untreated is about 1/3,
but if they get cooled,
the risk comes down to more
like 1/4 of the babies.
So clearly this has been
an effective therapy.
But I show this slide to remind us
that we still have room for improvement,
I mean, that's still not acceptable,
we want to get that down
to zero if possible.
So that's how I came into the picture.
So, after this came about,
now the big question is
what can we add to cooling?
Now that cooling is
standard of care in the US,
what can we add to cooling to further help
the brain recover and have less injury
and less longterm implications after HIE.
And I'm gonna talk first
about erythropoietin
and then talk about
some of the other things
that are coming down the pipeline.
So, erythropoietin, everyone
always asks me, epo?
Like what does that have
to do with the brain?
Everyone's heard of epo if you have
any sort of medical background,
it's also just one of the most, you know,
widely prescribed drugs
in medicare records
for treatment of anemia.
So erythropoietin is
essentially a hormone,
it's produced by the liver in the fetus
and then eventually in the kidney.
And so it regulates hematopoiesis.
And it wasn't until the early 90s
that people started noticing that there
were epo receptors in neurons in mice.
And then a few years later it was reported
also in human neurons
in all different ages
and so that started raising
people's, you know, eyebrows.
Why are there are epo
receptors in the brain?
This is just a schematic showing
that epo is actually quite abundant
and the receptor is quite abundant.
And so epo is made both in
astrocytes an in neurons.
In this diagram, epo is
represented by little yellow dots.
And then the receptor is
these little red ovals
and the receptor is
ubiquitous in the brain,
so not only on neurons and astrocytes
but also on microglial
cells and endothelial cells.
And so what has been worked out
is that when the brain
is exposed to hypoxia,
this turns on a whole, you know,
array of intracellular pathways.
It turns on the HIF-1 gene,
which then turns on
the erythropoietin gene
and then that leads to increased epo,
endogenous epo production,
there's also increased
epo receptor production.
And it's thought that this is sort of
an endogenous mechanism to
protect the brain from hypoxia.
And the question that
people are asking now,
is if that's the case, that
when you have this insult,
that the body starts turning on epo,
what if you gave even more epo?
Could you actually help the
brain recover even more?
And so what exactly is
epo doing in the brain?
And this is a slide that my collaborator
Sandra Juul put together, I
just think it's beautiful,
I love showing this slide.
But it summarizes so much information.
So the first thing to know from this slide
is that there are both acute
effects and longterm effects.
The acute effects are sort
of similar to hypothermia.
I showed earlier all
those different things
that hypothermia does,
well epo does a lot of the same things.
It has anti-inflammatory properties,
you know, it decreases excitotixicity,
oxidative stress, all of these things.
And all that is thought to
lead to improved survival.
So sort of similar to hypothermia.
But one of the great benefits
of epo we think is that
in addition to all of these
neuroprotective mechanisms,
there are also longterm effects.
And so as you mentioned earlier,
it's an erythropoietic agent
and so this may lead to
helping repair the brain.
It also has angiogenic properties,
so you have more, you
know, repair of vessels.
This one is really intriguing
and it's been studied a lot
by my colleagues at UCSF,
Fernando Gonzalez, who's a
neonatologist and Donna Ferriero.
What they found is that if you give
multiple high doses of epo,
you can actually have stem
cells in the brain after injury
preferentially become
neurons and oligodendrocytes.
And they've actually shown that
those migrate to the are of injury.
And so it seems to not just reduce injury
but actually enhance repair.
I don't show a lot of their data
because we don't have too much time
but it's really fascinating.
I mentioned that, you know,
there's a lot of preclinical
studies done of HIE
and specifically of the
effect of erythropoietin.
And so you know by now,
there are actually probably,
you know, even more than 70 animal studies
and specifically in
neonatal animal studies
that show that when you
give multiple doses of epo,
that the brain has both
histologic signs of improvement,
you know, when looking
under the microscope,
but also that the animals do better,
they have functional improvements.
And in general when you
look at these studies,
there is a 40 to 75% decrease in the size
of the brain lesion in animals
that are treated with epo
and I'll show you an example of that.
So these are data from my collaborator,
Fernando Gonzalez at UCSF.
So he has a rat model
of stroke essentially.
So what they do is they
do a carotid artery
ligation on one side of the neck
and that decreases blood flow
to that side of the brain
and you get a hole in the
brain, so you get a stroke.
But what they found is that,
here is an animal, a typical
animal with no treatment.
If there are three doses of epo given,
there is a remarkable
recovery of that brain.
I mean it's really dramatic.
But you know, this is just one example.
So then they put all
their animals together
and let me just go through
this graph for you.
This is, on the Y axis,
it's plotting the ratio
of the volume of brain on the injured side
versus the uninjured side,
and so it should be one,
it should be equal on the two sides.
And so the black bar are the
animals that have the injury,
sorry, the black bar is the
animals that have no injury
and so the ratio is one to one.
The blue bar are the animals
who have the injury but no treatment.
And you can see that, you know,
the volume of brain on this
side is, you know, like a 1/3,
I guess maybe 40% of what
it is on the other side.
The yellow bar represents
animals who have injury
who got one dose of epo only and that dose
was given right away after
the brain was injured
and there's no difference.
The red bar refers to
animals that got three doses
of epo right away after the injury,
24 hours later, and then seven days later.
And what it shows is that there is
a remarkable recovery of brain.
And then they actually
did this functional study,
so the Morris water maze, you know,
it tests the rat's like
memory and ability to swim.
And they found that the epo three rats,
the ones that got three doses,
did just as well as the normal rats.
So it's not just that it looked better,
these rats actually performed better.
And he actually has a lot of
other really interesting data,
I didn't have time to show but
it's quite intriguing in the animal data.
So then, you know, whenever
you think about studying
a new therapy on newborns,
you wanna make sure it's safe.
One of the initial issues
that came up was that
around the time when I started
coming into the picture
and being interested
in testing this therapy
in the babies that we were treating,
the FDA put a black box
warning on erythropoietin.
This is in, I think 2009 maybe?
And the reason is adults get epo a lot
for a variety of reasons
and it's been shown
to cause hypertension, clotting problems.
You know, if you're getting
treated because you have cancer
and you're going through chemotherapy,
there's actually increased tumor growth,
it is a growth factor.
Oh and those being tested
for adults with stroke,
adults could recover brain like this
and turned out that that
was very disappointing,
the very large trials showed
that there was increased death.
And so this black box warning came about.
Fortunately, we also use
epo already in babies.
We use it really to treat
anemia of prematurity.
I actually went through and searched
and found 33 clinical trials of epo
being used to treat anemia of prematurity
and the doses were all over the place
but as high as 7500
units per kilo per week.
And you know, if you add up all the babies
in those trails that got epo,
it was up to 2700 babies,
no concerns for safety.
And then, you know, it's
been studied in preterms,
we're not gonna talk too
much about preterms today
but as you know, half of CP is
from brain injury of prematurity
and it's being studied in that population.
And again, there've been
over 1000 babies studied
and really have not seen a lot of concern.
So with that in mind,
we decide to start off
with a very small simple
phase one clinical trial.
So typically a phase one trial
is one where you're looking to figure out
when the small number
of patients, is it safe?
You know, what's the best dose?
And so what we did was we enrolled,
I think I say that, yeah,
we enrolled 24 babies.
And the first three got
just 250 unites per kilo,
then six babies got this dose,
seven babies got 1000 unites per kilo.
And then assuming, you know,
every time we saw no safety,
we were allowed to go up in the dose.
The question here is what is the best dose
to use to treat babies?
And the way we tried to get at that answer
and of course there's
no way to know for sure
but the best way to guide that question
is to look at what's been
studied in animal models.
And animal models suggest that if you
can get a plasma level to this range,
that that's most neuroprotective.
If it's higher, it was
not working that well
and if it was lower, it
was not working very well.
And what we found was these seven babies
that got 1000 units all
fell within that range,
got, you know, blood levels in that range.
And also it was the first time
that epo had been given with hypothermia
and so the question was,
you know, can that be done?
And there were no safety concerns.
So following this phase one trial,
we were funded by the
Thrasher Research Fund
to do a phase two study.
And so this is actually a true, you know,
randomized placebo controlled
double masked clinical trial
where we enrolled 50 babies.
And what we did was all
the babies were cooled,
again that's become standard of care,
this is just, you know, days
of age on this axis here.
And then on days one, two,
three, five, and seven,
we gave a dose of epo,
the 1000 unites per kilo
that we had found in the phase one study.
And then all the babies, as
part of clinical practice,
get a brain MRI after they're rewarmed.
And then we followed
them by phone initially
and then at one year we brought them in
to do a neurodevelopmental evaluation
and I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
So this slide just shows
you who was in our study.
It turns out when we're all done,
we found out that 24
babies had been randomized
in getting the therapy, the epo doses
and 26 had gotten hypothermia
alone with placebo.
And this just shows that the
two groups are quite similar
in terms of, you know, basic demographics,
in terms of how sick they were
with regards to their low Apgar scores,
how they were delivered,
you know, cesarean section,
an emergency section was actually
required in a fair number,
71% in one group and 58% in the other.
And severe HIE was equally
distributed between the two.
So the first question we asked was how did
these two groups differ in
terms of their brain MRIs?
So as I mentioned, after
babies are rewarmed,
typically they get an
MRI shortly thereafter.
And our group, our collaborators
at Washington University
had created and published a scoring system
that specifically looks at
how badly the basal ganglia
and then this parasagittal injury looks
in these babies with HIE.
And so they didn't know which
group the babies were in
and they scored both the location
and the severity of the injury.
And what we found was that
the babies that got epo
overall had a lower
MRI global injury score
than the group with placebo.
And this was actually
quite surprising to us
because it was a small study.
And again, like these
are the different parts
of the brain that were being scored
but when you put the injury all together,
there was less injury in
the epo treated group.
This slide shows that it's
actually quite striking
in that if you break down
the severity of injury
in the brain into these
categories, mild, moderate, severe,
that moderate to severe
injury was only present
in one of the epo treated babies
and 11 of the placebo treated
babies, so pretty striking.
The MRI is just a biomarker,
what we really care about is function
and so in this small phase two trial,
we were only funded to follow
them until 12 months of age.
So we did the best we could at 12 months.
We first administered WIDEA,
which is a parental questionnaire.
And this questionnaire,
you ask parents about
all these different, you know,
self care, mobility, communication,
and social cognition milestones.
So that was a questionnaire
we administered.
We also use the Alberto
Infant Motor Scale,
which is a standardized motor evaluation,
it's basically just seeing
how well the baby does
in prone, supine, sitting,
and standing positions.
And what we found was at 12 months,
when we looked at the questionnaire,
overall there was no significant
difference between the groups
but if you look at the sub scales,
the mobility scale actually was,
the scores were definitely lower
in the epo group than the placebo group
and that was just barely
significant difference.
And this was corroborated by
the Alberto Infant Motor Scale,
which again, the scores were higher,
meaning there was better motor development
in the epo treated group
than placebo group.
And again, this was by evaluators
who were masked to the treatment group
that the child was assigned to.
So these were exciting results.
We thought that this study concluded
that this combination treatment
of epo plus hypothermia
may reduce the severity of injury on MRI
and may improve short term outcomes.
But I definitely wanted
to spend a little time
reminding us that this is a small study
and it has major limitations
because of its small sample size
and because we didn't
have longterm outcomes.
And to really illustrate that point,
I wanted to show these data to you.
So as I mentioned, this
Alberta Infant Motor Score,
the scores were higher, meaning
there was better development
in the epo treated group
than the placebo group.
Well it turns out that
in this small study,
we found that there were two patients
who had post hoc diagnoses of exclusion,
meaning that, you know, when
you first enroll these babies,
they have to be enrolled
by 24 hours of age.
You don't actually know everything
going on with this baby yet.
Two of them were found out during the rest
of their neonatal stay in the hospital,
that they had other conditions
that were gonna make them
have really bad outcomes.
One had myotonic dystrophy,
significant muscle disorder.
Another one had a very bad
brainstem malformation,
who actually died at one year of age,
a little bit past one year of age.
And it just turns out,
because it's a small study,
both of those were in the placebo group
and so they were going to
do poorly no matter what.
If you take them out,
then the difference is
really less striking and
definitely no longer significant.
So just a good reminder
of why this is interesting
in that this study we were able to show
why it's really important
with small studies
to be careful what you conclude.
And therefore I think
we have equipoise still.
There really is not enough evidence
to justify using this therapy.
And I will say part of the reason is,
so there are three large
ongoing phase three trials,
we're now doing a large phase three trial
we're calling HEAL.
The Australian group, led by Helen Liley
is doing a large study with 300 babies,
these are all epo plus hypothermia trials.
This group, Juliana Patkai in Paris
had to stop their study early,
they were gonna enroll
300 but the reason was
with this small number, they
actually found increased deaths
in the epo treated group.
So that gives us pause,
gives all of you pause as I just heard.
So I think, you know, the jury's still out
as to what we're gonna
find but fingers crossed.
So we actually, we were funded by NIH
to perform this large phase three trial
and Sandra Juul is a neonatologist
up at University of Washington
who has spent her entire career studying
how epo provides
neuroprotection to infants.
And so just to give you an
idea of what we're doing,
this is sort of a similar
slide as you saw earlier.
So again, these babies
are all getting cooled
for the first three days, which
is standard clinical care.
We're actually front
loading the doses this time,
we're giving four doses
on days one through four
and then a final dose on day seven.
Donna Ferriero feels very
strongly and Fernando Gonzalez,
that this late dose is the most important
for helping the brain repair
and they have some data to suggest that.
And then we're collecting
blood and urine samples.
This time we're following them by phone
at four, eight, 12, and 18 months
and then seeing them
for a full evaluation,
including a Bayley Three
standardized neuro exam.
And you know, some other additional
evaluations at 24 months.
This is just a slide showing that we have
17 hospitals enrolling
babies around the country.
And our goal is we have to enroll 500
to show that there's benefit to this.
And so we're up to 180,
actually this morning we just enrolled 181
and so we'll be done with
enrollment in a year and a half
and then we have to follow the
babies for another two years.
And so it'll be 2022
before we know the answer.
One of the exciting things
is that Australian study
is using a very similar,
almost identical protocol
and so it may be that we can combine
our data as well with them,
if we don't have enough power
even with this study of 500
to get a better handle on
whether the therapy works.
Okay, so I think we're
doing pretty well for time,
so I have a little bit of time to tell you
about some of the other
things that are being studied
and I kind of cut this section down
for fear of not having enough time
but I think it's really interesting
to think about what
else is being looked at.
So xenon, xenon is a
noble gas, which you know,
from high school chemistry
you might remember
what that means, I barely remember.
But I guess it's present in trace amounts
in the atmosphere and it
was the first noble gas
to actually be synthesized in a lab
and it has incredibly potent
neuroprotective effects.
And you know, through this pathway,
it up-regulates all
these survival proteins,
including HIF-1 I had mentioned earlier.
So if you give xenon gas,
you're also gonna increase epo,
as well as a lot of other
upstream survival proteins.
And you know, a lot of anesthetic agents,
you've probably followed
this a little bit,
that they've been found
in a lot of animal studies
to cause injury to developing brain.
And so we are very reluctant now
to sedate babies for
MRI and things like that
because of that potential risk
of it being harmful to the brain.
But unlike the other anesthetics,
xenon is an anesthetic agent that
does not cause any sort of injury
to the brain in animal studies.
The problem is that
xenon is very expensive
and therefore you have to use
this closed circuit device
that will recycle the xenon
and it's also not FDA approved in the US.
It's been approved in
Europe and Russia for
at least five, 10 years to be
used as an anesthetic agent
but it's not available in the US.
So just to give you some ideas,
in England they're the
ones that have taken
the lead in studying this for HIE.
Marianne Thoresen did this
study, so she's actually,
she created this very complex,
I think, recycling system.
And what she did was she gave 50% xenon
for 18 hours plus hypothermia
and what she found in these 14 babies
was that it seemed safe.
Again, this is one of
those phase one studies,
you're looking at safety and feasibility.
And interestingly they found that whenever
they stopped the xenon, not whenever,
but often when they stopped the xenon,
the baby would start seizing.
And then they would start it again
and the baby would stop seizing.
So they got the sense that it seemed
to have anti-epileptic properties.
Then there's another
group, Denis Azzopardi,
he's another neonatologist in the UK
and they've done a larger study,
where they enrolled 130 babies.
They called this the TOBY Xenon trial
and they gave a slightly
smaller dose, 30% xenon,
started by 12 hours and
inhale for 24 hours.
This is again, with hypothermia.
And they looked at the
short term outcomes,
which is MRI findings, which
they used as a biomarker
to see if this treatment might
actually lead to less brain injury.
And it was quite
disappointing that there were
actually no differences in the two groups
in terms of these early
neuroimaging biomarkers.
But they also saw a reduction in seizures,
so that probably is gonna be interesting.
But I asked him last year actually
and it sounds like they're not
gonna have longterm follow up
which is just so disappointing.
I think it's a funding issue
and I think he's somewhat retired,
so I'm not sure we're gonna
actually learn too much more about that.
So that's one thing, that's
one story I've been following.
This is another one, which
also was a surprise to me
because I have this bottle by my bed
and I had no idea that it would
have neuroprotective properties.
So you know, similar
to what we talked about
with epo and with hypothermia,
it has multiple properties
in animal studies
and that could be
potentially neuroprotective.
And there are a number of
human studies going on,
they're two phased, two studies,
one that's been published
and one that's ongoing
looking at different doses.
And so stay tuned, you know,
the idea is that this
is, you know, very safe
and it's being studied with
hypothermia in this study.
But also as a monotherapy,
perhaps in places
where cooling is not available.
So that's another story that'll
be interesting to follow.
I took this picture of an
article in Consumer Reports,
it came out in I think January,
it was a great article.
And you know, some of the
other speakers and I talked
about stem cell therapy, it
comes up a lot in my clinic,
people ask about all
sorts of clinics out there
that are coming around that offer,
you know, everything under the sun.
And this article actually
in Consumer Reports,
if you wanna go see it, they
actually talk a lot about
what the FDA has and has not done
to try to regulate those clinics,
it's a really interesting article.
In Consumer Reports of all places.
So stem cells, is there a role?
I think really the main therapy
that's being tested right
now is autologous cord blood.
And so, you know, this is relatively safe,
you know, it's noninvasive
and people talk about
having minimal ethical issues.
The umbilical cord is actually
considered medical waste
and so taking the cord blood
and then administering
it back to the baby,
animal studies show
promise, although no one
really understand a mechanism
by which it might work.
I know of two studies that are going on,
one is Michael Cotten's study at Duke
and they're cooling babies with HIE
and then also giving stem
cells from cord blood.
From clinicaltrials.gov, it looked like
they would be done in 2019.
I actually don't know
how far along they are.
There's also a smaller phase one study
at New York Medical Center.
This was interesting
because they're not only
giving cord blood in these three aliquots
on day zero, three, and seven
but they're also taking the placenta
and extracting placental derived
stem cells and giving that.
So they're actually giving
five aliquots of stem cells,
so that'll be really interesting
to see what happens with that as well.
I like this slide because I
think it really summarizes
all the things that are unknown,
there's just so many
more unanswered questions
in terms of how to use stem cells and why.
So you know, certainly human
umbilical cord blood cells,
you know, provide mesenchymal stem cells
that do eventually become
neurons and glial cells
but there's just so much we don't know.
We don't know what kind of
cell is working, how it works.
We don't know how many cells to give,
how often to give it, what's
the best way to give it.
You know, Frank Frambell
in the Netherlands
has studied giving it intranasally.
A group down in southern California,
you know, they give it
directly intracranially,
this is in animal studies of course.
You know, a lot of other animal studies
give it intraperitoneally.
You know, when should you give it
and which patients would benefit
and exactly how it works,
you know, what are the
actual humeral factors
that are being released that are actually
probably the most beneficial?
We just don't know answers
to all of these questions,
so I think it's still
really early in this field.
And I wanted to mention that, you know,
we just focused on erythropoietin
because that's what I'm studying
and it's the most well studied
of all the cooling plus therapies
that are being, you know,
brought down the pipeline
but there are many others.
So there are actually clinical trials
looking at magnesium sulfate.
So we know that that is a, you know,
potent neuroprotective
agent in preterm infants
and can prevent CP in preterms.
It's also being studied in terms.
Allopurinol is being
studied in Europe right now.
N-Acetyl Cysteine is
specifically anti-inflammatory.
Cannabinoids, there's actually a company
that wants to study this in addition
to hyperthermia for HIE.
And so the thought is perhaps
one day down the line,
we can actually tailor a cocktail
of neuroprotective therapies
for individual patients
and continue to cool them.
This is from my mentor Donna Ferriero
but I thought it was kinda cute.
So that's it, I hope
you got a sense as to,
you know, why we're interested in HIE,
some of the current therapies
and therapies that are
coming down the line.
I wanted to thank my collaborators
and specifically my three main mentors,
who've been Donna Ferriero
and Roberta Ballard
and Sandra Juul, who I talked about
up at University of Washington.
And Thrasher Research
Fund for funding our work
and then finally, yeah,
this is a little girl
that was in our phase two study of epo
and she's done so well and we want
all our patients to
end up like this, yeah.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)